- This video is brought to you by Keeps.
(laid-back hip-hop music)
What up Wisecrack, Greg here.
Have you been hustling lately?
It seems like everybody is.
Whether you're busting your
balls at the nine-to-five,
or adding an Uber shift at night,
or selling your knitted frogs
on Etsy: the hustle is real.
The culture surrounding hustling
means that rest is our last priority.
Hustle culture encourages
us to spend our free time
pursuing money, and economic stability,
by any means necessary.
It's the embodiment of
the classic philosophy
of pulling oneself up by the
bootstraps to make ends meet,
especially in today's
tough economic climate.
But, ironically, the term "bootstrapping",
coined in the 1800s,
was initially intended
to reference something
being literally impossible.
Impossible like, pulling
yourself over a fence
by the straps of your boots.
Or crossing a river by
the straps of your boots.
Or flying to the moon by
Yet today, the phrase basically means
you can overcome all barriers to success
through sheer determination and hard work.
The bootstraps narrative
tells us that no matter what,
if we work hard enough, we
will eventually be successful,
just like those self-made millionaires
who struck gold with just a small,
$1 million loan from their parents.
And hustle culture success stories
are endlessly parroted by the mass media.
Often, these success stories
come from celebrities
using existing social media
clout to, say, push diet teas,
perfumes, or even stoner pottery.
And while it may have worked for Rihanna,
most of us are in a more hopeless place.
So, today we're gonna ask:
is hustle culture a
positive motivational force,
or is it just a buzzword
used to make us feel bad
for using our free time to relax?
- [Princess Carolyn]
Starting now, you are a hard,
heartless career gal.
Go to work, be awesome at it,
and don't waste time on
foolish flights of fancy!
From now on, you are a robot!
Beep, bop, boop, blorp, bleep.
- Let's find out in this Wisecrack Edition
on Hustle Culture: Is It Bad For Us?
But before we get into it,
I want to tell you about
this week's sponsor, Keeps.
Keeps makes it easier and more affordable
for guys to prevent hair loss.
And sine two out of three men
will experience male pattern
baldness in some form
by the time they're 35,
Keeps is relevant to a
lot of people out there.
But with their subscription service,
you can fight back against hair loss
and hang on to the locks you've got.
The Keeps process begins
with a free consultation
with a licensed Keeps doctor,
who can help decide which combination
of FDA-approved prescriptions
and over-the-counter
medications are right for you.
These hair loss prevention medications
will arrive at your
doorstep every three months,
so you won't have to set a pesky reminder
to pick up refills.
As your treatment plan goes on,
you can message your Keeps doctor 24/7
to update them on your progress
and to ask any questions you may have.
But here's one question we
can answer right off the bat:
while individual results may vary,
it typically takes between
four and six months
to start seeing results.
If you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss,
go to keeps.com/wisecrack
or click the link in the description
and receive 50% off your first order.
That's K-E-E-P-S.com/wisecrack.
Now back to the show.
While treated like a
contemporary phenomenon,
hustle culture actually has
roots in the late 1800s.
At the time, many folks
suffered from burnout.
That's in part because many of them
were working much longer hours
due to the advent of electricity
and the pressures of the
industrial revolution.
Some of these folks were even diagnosed
with a medical condition
then known as neurasthenia.
Its symptoms were depression,
insomnia, fatigue,
and other mental and physical ailments
which we now associate with
millennial and Gen-Z burnout.
But here's the thing:
getting a neurasthenia diagnosis
wasn't strictly negative.
It meant you were faithfully conforming
to the idealized Protestant
work ethic of the time.
These symptoms were
considered a natural part
of having an active mind,
and being a good, hard-working American.
In fact, an alternative
name was American-itis.
Naturally, miracle cures like
Rexall's American-itis Elixir
were marketed to the anxious patients.
Those suffering from American-itis
were given treatment
recommendations like self-care.
It's like how we're told that
a few minutes of meditation
each morning will cure our
own modern American-itis.
Still there was one big caveat:
This disease wasn't for everyone.
The man who coined the term, George Beard,
believed that Black and Indigenous people
could not suffer from neurasthenia,
because they didn't overuse their minds.
He thought the same
about working-class Americans in general.
The diagnosis was basically exclusive
to white, middle-class Americans,
who were supposedly
over-using their brain power
to pursue the American dream.
Which was all well and good,
but maybe a little elixir
could take the edge off, right?
In contrast, for marginalized groups,
working to the point of exhaustion
wasn't seen as a treatable condition.
It was an expectation,
the only way of achieving
social and economic mobility.
This is how the concept of the hustle
emerged in Black communities.
The hustle wasn't an option;
it was a requirement.
If Black folks weren't hustling,
they were even stereotyped
as straight-up lazy.
There was tons of pressure
to be the model minority,
miraculously succeeding in
a system rigged against you.
Keeping up with the hustle
was, and has remained,
a matter of literal survival
for Black Americans.
It's only recently that
the term hustle culture
has become commonly
appropriated by white people.
But the timing of this
particular appropriation
over recent years is interesting.
That's because it coincides
with diminishing economic
conditions across the board
for middle- and working-class
people at large.
Today, society applies
the same shaming rhetoric
to practically everybody, though
especially people of color.
If you're cobbling together
a 70-hour work week
and still not getting by?
Well, the system isn't the
problem, man. You're the problem.
Whether it's called
American-itis or the hustle,
working your butt off
has long been intrinsic
to the American dream.
Now, that used to mean
working for the same company
your whole life, rising through the ranks,
and buying a home.
And, of course, earning a retirement
filled with comfort and Caribbean cruises.
But in recent decades, as
jobs became less secure,
that old-school American
Dream was slowly replaced
by the ubiquitous ethos of Hustle Culture.
Nowadays, we're told that the
way to achieve true happiness
and economic freedom isn't
from working hard at one job
your entire life and climbing
the corporate ladder.
It's from balancing multiple jobs,
cultivating a unique side hustle,
and maybe striking gold on a
late-night Doge-coin trade.
But why is this all
happening in the first place?
That is to say: When did hustle culture
become so deeply entrenched in our society
that people are getting up at
3:00 a.m. to drive for Uber,
before a full day of work?
A lot of it seems to be the
result of one major shift:
the erosion of labor unions,
which provide a means
for the working class
to build collective power.
Since a bunch of shoemakers
first unionized in 1794,
American unions have been a
way for working-class folks
to fight back against
unfair working conditions.
During the second Industrial Revolution,
they achieved things like higher pay,
safer conditions, and shorter workdays.
Back then, unions fought especially hard
for a 40-hour work week.
Yet today, high-profile business people
like Elon Musk tweet things like
nobody has ever changed the
world on 40 hours a week.
And Silicon Valley employees wear T-shirts
declaring 9 to 5 is for the weak.
Damn! So, what's changed?
Union membership has
declined, and dramatically.
In post-war America, 35% of
the workforce were in a union.
In 1983, that fell to
20%, and by 2020, to 11%.
Some of this is because sectors
which had high union
density have declined,
says Cornell professor
Kate Bronfenbrenner.
Simultaneously, a high number of jobs
have been created in
newer sectors, like tech,
where unions haven't existed before.
Union suppression is also rife,
with companies from Amazon
to Tesla to Starbucks
actively discouraging their
workers from joining unions.
Tech companies in Silicon Valley
even introduce measures like casual dress,
margarita Fridays and free food
to try and reduce union
membership amongst its workers.
But it doesn't stop at
petty attempts to please.
Elon Musk illegally coerced employees
into not joining unions when he tweeted,
"Why pay union dues and give
up stock options for nothing?"
So, what does this decline
in union membership say
about hustle culture?
Well, with fewer people collectivizing
to demand a living wage and better hours,
we have less control over our income.
Indeed, it's no wonder that
the stagnation of wages
overlaps with the stagnation of unions.
Instead of focusing on the collective,
we're going at it alone
to try and outpace our
colleagues and climb the ladder.
If working conditions are intolerable,
it's not on our bosses for
denying us bathroom breaks.
The responsibility is on us
to manage our own stress.
But it's not just the demise of unions
that has played a role in
promoting hustle culture.
It's also the way overworking
has been repackaged as proof of worth.
Hustle culture has a way
of changing the narrative
from your boss is a dick
for making you work weekends
to you're doing a great job
if you're working weekends.
And if you're not,
maybe you're just not working hard enough.
Under the prevailing
hustle culture narrative,
when we rise up the ladder
due to working overtime or multiple jobs,
it's not exploitation;
it's a success story.
That's even if the odds
are stacked against you.
If women are having a hard time
succeeding in the workplace,
they can now girlboss their way out of it.
- If Angelica's ever going to make it
in a male-dominated power structure,
she's gotta eat, breathe,
drink and sweat self-esteem!
- When Yahoo CEO Marissa Mayer
boasted of her 130-hour work weeks,
she wasn't being overworked
by an understaffed company.
She was girlbossing.
The problem is the
narrative of the girlboss
takes our attention away
from systemic issues,
specifically, the numerous barriers
that women, and especially women of color,
already face in the workplace.
You know, lower wages,
discriminatory hiring
and promotion policies,
inadequate maternity leave, and so on.
Instead, our culture
focuses on success stories
of Marissa Mayer spending
18 hours a day at her desk.
And then we wonder why we
aren't doing that, too.
Hustling also presents a way for people
pushed out of the traditional
job market to get by.
Being your own boss is presented
as a way to navigate systemic racism
and other barriers to success.
And both the gig economy and side hustling
have grown with digital platforms.
Doing casual freelance
work in your free time
is easier than ever via
apps like Uber, Lyft,
Fiverr, TaskRabbit, and so on.
In this way, recent tech has, ironically,
helped us move away from the utopian dream
that the technology industry
preached in its early days.
See, the prevailing notion used to be
that innovative technology
would increase productivity so much
that we wouldn't have to work
nine-to-five jobs anymore.
Hypothetically, we'd all
have a lot more free time.
Now, innovative tech just
seems to find more ways
to fill our free time with more work.
This is made all the more
depressing by the reality
it's really hard to gain
a significant income
from side hustles.
A survey from Bankrate
found that the average
monthly earnings from a side
hustle were $686 a month.
Notably, though, 49% of respondents
were making less than $200 a month.
The dream of eventually earning your way
out of your day job, then,
rarely becomes a reality for most folks.
But that doesn't fully
explain why hustle culture
has become so dominant in recent years.
One of the things that makes
hustle culture so appealing
is the notion that by working really hard,
accumulating major achievements,
and earning lots of money,
we will eventually become happy.
Of course, you can't experience
the joys of high achievement
and mega-bucks unless
you're being productive,
which is why hustle
culture depends on the idea
of productivity being tied to self-worth.
Constantly working is seen as a positive,
rather than as a sign you're
not being paid enough.
- Work's...
Work's going okay, I would say. Yup.
Working hard.
- One of the symptoms of an
approaching nervous breakdown
is the belief that one's
work is every so important.
That's Bertrand Russell.
- Huh.
Yes, indeed. Yes.
Yes to that.
- This leads to toxic productivity.
That's where your self-worth
is so tied to your productivity
that unless you're doing something
which benefits you financially,
you're wasting your time.
When we're valued by
how much we can achieve,
and especially by how much we earn,
the consequences can be devastating.
If we're not making a profit,
we're not just economically worthless;
we're literally worthless.
It's no wonder, then,
that job-related busy-ness
has become a status symbol.
In one experiment,
participants were presented
with a hypothetical man:
One who either worked long
hours and was really busy,
or one who didn't work
and enjoyed leisure time.
As you might guess,
the busy man was considered
more high-status.
But what are the
consequences of this pressure
to never stop working?
We've all heard the
uplifting/low-key dystopian stories
of hustle culture in action;
the Lyft driver who kept
working while in labor,
the girl who sells lemonade
to fund her brain surgery,
and so on.
There's no set answer
as to how often hustle
culture actually works.
A lot of it, as we see from celebrities
and the extremely wealthy,
has to do with having existing capital
to invest into new projects
or existing fame to leverage
your side hustle off of.
That's not to mention being
able to afford nannies,
chefs, cleaners and assistants
to do the tasks that normal
people have to juggle
alongside their multiple jobs.
The mythos of the hustle
is far less realistic
if you're not already rich.
So what about the rest of us?
Well, the stress of hustling
may be reducing our life span,
increasing our risk of dying
from a stroke or heart disease,
and other scary stats you can
Google in the dead of night.
And ironically, studies show
that working these long
hours and multitasking
is also reducing our
all-important productivity.
So, we're sacrificing our health,
well-being, and free time,
all in the name of the mythical hustle
that, at the end of the day,
probably won't salvage
our bank accounts anyway.
So is hustle culture here to stay?
The coronavirus pandemic
was an interesting wildcard.
Obviously, it left a lot of
us working from our bedrooms,
living rooms, and
apparently even bathrooms.
This certainly had its positives,
like greater accessibility
for people with disabilities
and more flexibility for all of us.
But we were also expected
to be even more productive,
without water cooler talk to distract us.
So it's no surprise that one survey found
that 68% of remote
workers worked weekends,
and 45% regularly did more
than eight hours of work a day.
In the UK, remote workers
have done $33 billion
worth of unpaid overtime.
But it's not just how hard
you work at your actual job.
Hobbies became commodified
into side-hustles,
especially in industries like
entertainment and journalism.
People tried desperately
to supplement lost income
from being unable to work,
or losing their jobs.
So in some ways,
the pandemic arguably
exacerbated hustle culture.
But, on the flip side,
there's a growing movement
against the notion
that we have to spend our free time
doing profit-oriented work.
Hustle culture likes to tell us
that the only reason we exist
is to make money and achieve success.
But people are pushing
back against the idea,
arguing that profit-minded work
is not our only purpose on this planet.
Activists have been promoting
rest as a form of resistance,
asking questions like:
How will you be useless
to capitalism today?
Books like "Laziness Does Not Exist"
remind us that toxic
productivity isn't good for us
and that laziness might
just be a societal concept
invented to make us feel bad
for enjoying our downtime.
Whether this movement will have an effect
on hustle culture at
large remains to be seen.
But what do you think, Wisecrack?
Is hustle culture a way
of motivating people
to live their best life
selling knitted frogs on Etsy,
or is it a con designed
to make us feel bad
for spending our free
time watching Netflix
and enjoying junk food?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
for all your support.
Check out our side hustle by
listening to our podcasts.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're clocking in for a 12-hour day.
And don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat hip hop music)
Rexall's American-it is Elixir
were marketed to those anxious patient-
Were marketed to those ancient-
To the ancient parent-
Anxious patients.
Ancients patients.